I'm dr. Keller and if you're looking to  prevent a hangover the next day go on  for one and i don't mean one for one  with your body i mean one alcoholic  drink to one glass of water the main  issue people get hangovers it's because  they're dehydrated alcohol is a diuretic  which means you're going to pee out a  lot of water and with that is going to  come a lot of electrolytes and that is  going to make you feel parched and dry  mouth and feel a headache tomorrow  because of your shrunken brain so if you  want to prevent that drink water from  the get-go I say start off with a glass  of water and then after every alcoholic  drink have another full glass of water  not only will this keep you hydrated  it's also going to slow down your  consumption of alcohol so you'll trick  yourself into place in just a little bit  more alright in order here dr. Keller  and there's any over tip for you  you